[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا ومتابعينا من جديد الصين
التي لعبت دورا بارزا في الوساطه في
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني الاستئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه رحبت بقبول الاطراف
هذا الاتفاق والاعلان عنها الخارجيه
الصينيه افادت بانها تتطلع الى رؤيه
اتصالات وحوار اوثق بين السعوديه وايران
معربه عن استعدادها لمواصله لعب دور
ايجابي وبناء في تسهيل هذه الجهود ونوهت
الوزاره الصينيه بان تظافر الجهود
والتنسيق بين جميع الاطراف المعنيه خلال
المحادثات بين السعوديه وايران في بكين
اسفرت عن نتائج مهمه كما اعربت بيكين عن
املها في الاتفاقيه ووضع خارطه الطريق
وجدول زمني لتحسين العلاقات سيوفر اساسا
متينا للبلدين لبدء فصل جديد في علاقاتهما
الثنائيه
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني مصدر سعودي
للعربي
الاتفاق مع ايران ينص على الالتزام
باحترام السياده ووقف التدخلات
الاتفاقيات مع ايران توضح اهميه ما سيترتب
عليها من فرص ايجابيه
الاتفاق مع ايران على حل الخلافات بالطرق
السلبيه يشمل جميع الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه
نامل ان ينعكس الاتفاق مع ايران ايجابيا
على كل ملفات واسمات المنطقه
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من امستردام
يعقوب سعيد الباحث في شان الايراني اهلا
بك من بكين صحفيه نادر رونج اهلا بكم
ضيوفي اسمحولي ان ابدا منبكي معك سيد نادر
طالما نتحدث عن الوساطه الصينيه وعن ان
الصين قادر ان تضمن نجاح هذه الاتفاقيه
سؤال المطروح على ما تراهن الصين ما
الملفات التي يمكن للصين ان تراهن عليها
لانجاح هذه الاتفاقيه
اهلا هو مرحبا بكم اولا الصين يعني
اهميتها في وسطها بانها يعني تحافظ على
علاقات جيده ويعني علاقات استراتيجيه
الشامله مع كلا من السعوديه وايران وكذلك
ايضا اكبر شريك
تجاريتين يعني لذلك هناك الثقل والعلاقات
الثنائيه مهمه بين واحدتين دولتين ولذلك
الصين اصبح يعني اكثر لديه اكثر يعني
تاهيلا لان تكون الوساطه بين البلدين
وكذلك ولكن
الفهم لماذا
ان تلقي بثقلها في هكذا وساطه هل ما يخصها
فقط ان تؤمن هذه المنطقه لحسابات اقتصاديه
ام انا للصين حسابات اخرى تتعلق بالنظام
الدولي هذا هذا المطروح
يعني تريد ان ترى
يعني
موحده ومزدهره وكذلك
المستقرا ويعني
يعني
وهذا يسب لصالح الجميع وليس للصين فحسب
الدول المنتجه والعالم كله فكذلك ما تفعله
الثاني هو ايضا
تلبيه
للمتطلبات الشعوب والدول هذه الدول على
المصالحه وعلى
السعي الى السلام
طيب وضحت الفكره ولكني ساعود لك بعد قليل
ساحاول ان ادخل في تفاصيل هذه الاستفاده
يعني بما يعني ما الافاده التي ستحصل للص
ين من خلال هكذا وساطه الى جانب
كل ما هو ملفات اقتصاديه ولكن استاذ يعقوب
هل الصين قدره حقيقيه على تثبيت هذه
الاتفاقيات ومما مدى قدره على ذلك ان كانت
نواياها فعلا بتثبيت هذه الاتفاقيه وبدعم
خطاها
تحيه طيبه لك ولمشاهدي قناه العربيه بكل
تاكيد يعني من الصين هي اليوم تشكل المنفذ
الوحيد لايران للعالم تمثل يعني الوجهه
الاساسيه اللي مبيعات النفط والاستثمار في
البنيه التحتيه الايرانيه وهي كانت ايضا
نظام الاساسي للتعاون الطهران مع المجتمع
الدولي في الملف النووي لكن يعني يبقى
احتمالات نجاح هذا الاتفاق والبناء عليه
يعني في الحقيقه يعتمد على ديناميت ودور
الصين اللي هي ايضا قيد الاختبار في نزاع
ومنطقه اقل ما يقال في انها شديده التعقيد
الصين هي اساسا يعني حديثه في هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي هي لا تعي يعني مدى تعقيداتها
واليوم يعني حتى بعد هذا الاتفاق لم نعرف
مثلا ما هي الشروط الجزائيه التي تطرحها
الصين نعم هي لا تجمعها علاقات مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ومع ايران وبالتالي قد
تقف من نفس المسافه ولكن اذا ما افترضنا
جدلا باعتبارها ان تلعب دور الوسيط اذا لم
[موسيقى]
الاتفاقيه
اعتقد يعني سيكون هناك نوع من هذا
التبادل او تنسيق
هناك يمكن ان نرى هناك التاثير الصيني
يعني
العلاقه التعاون الصيني كبير بين صين
وايران ولذلك كل هذه التعاون والثقل الصين
في سياساتها الخارجيه يعني سيؤثر على
ايران وكذلك اذا كان يعني ايران لا تلتزم
بهذا الاتفاق ستفكر في
العلاقاتها مع الصين وكذلك لا تستطيع ان
يعني
تخرب
الاتفاقيه على حساب علاقاتها مع الصين
كذلك يطرح موضوع الصينيه ويقول عبر تاريخ
الصين لطالما كانت
برغماتيه في تعاملها مع الملفات الشائكه
هل تعتقد بان مثل هكذا عامل قد يضع النقاط
على الحروف بعيدا عن العاطفه بعيدا عن دول
قادره ان تكون على معرفه بنوعيه هذه
المنطقه فعوضا بان تفيدها هي تظرها
بدخولها في حساسيات لا تنفع مسار حقيقي
جندي
في الحقيقه يعني انا اعتقد بانه يعني كما
اشرت اللحظه
الدور الصيني هو دور يعني حديث في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط اعتقد بانه هناك الكثير من
الملفات المعقده التي يعني تتصل بها هذه
العلاقه الشائكه بين ايران وبين السعوديه
ملفات لها علاقه بالداخل الايراني وبفكره
تصدير الثوره بالعقيده التي تتبناها
النظام وهو ملفات لها علاقه بالمنطقه
الاقليميه ابتداء من اليمن مرورا بالعراق
وسوريا ولبنان ايضا اليوم المشكله الكبيره
بانه الصين هي ايضا ليست فاعله كثيرا في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وليس لها دور كبير على
هذه على حلحله هذه الملفات مثل اليوم
الجانب الروسي يعني ممكن روسيا مثلا قد
تستطيع ان تلعب دور
في مرحله الملف السوري او في الوساطه
اليمانيه ولكن الصين باعتبارها يعني قوه
حديثه داخل هذه ستكون استاذ يعقوب لديها
خط الحرير الذي يمر من ايران فهي ستكون
حاضره وبالتالي يبدو بانها تحذر لما سيكون
فيما بعد
بكل تاكيد هي تحضر لذلك ونحن يعني هذا
العالم كله يشهد هذا التطور هذا هذا وجود
القوه الصينيه وبالتالي هذا لا يعني لا
يمكن لا يمكن لاحد انكارها وبالتالي هذا
واقع سواء في هذه المنطقه وفي الكثير من
المناطق ولكن السؤال هنا اليوم هي ما مدى
قدره الصين او ما مدى رغبتها في فرض شروط
جزائيه وفي ان تكون ان توتر علاقتها مع
ايران في حال ايران لم تلتزم بهذه الشروط
خاصه واليوم مثل يعني المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لديها الكثير من الخيارات الاخرى
في التعامل مع العلاقات الاقتصاديه ايران
ليس لدي هذا الخيار وبالتالي هذا كما هو
مصلحه اقتصاديه ايرانيه هي ايضا مصلحه
اقتصاديه صينيه الصين تاخذ ذلك بعين
الاعتبار وانا في الحقيقه لا اعتقد بان
الصين سوف تعرض
لعلاقات مع ايران في حال عدم التزامها قد
ربما يعني تتوتر على علاقه بشكل الاوقات
او قد تفرض بعض من النقاط ولكن مساله
النفط مساله المساله الاقتصاديه مساله
الاستثمار الكبير داخل يوم الحضور الصيني
داخل ايران بشكل يعني في الحقيقه غير مصدر
يعني لا يمكن لاحد تصديقه حضور كبير على
المستوى الاقتصاد الداخل الايراني على
المستوى البناء البنيه التحتيه لذلك كل
هذه الملفات لن تعرفها الصين الى الخطر
وبالتالي لن تنسحب في حال مثلا ايران لم
تلتزم بهذه الاتفاقيه سيد نادر منذ قليل
تحدثنا عن خط الحرير تحدثنا عن المصالح
الاستراتيجيه الاقتصاديه بين كل هذه الدول
ولكن البعض الاخر واعود الى نقطه البدايه
اللي كنت طرحتها يتحدث عن النظام العالمي
وعن ان الصين كذلك توسع نفوذه حتى وان كان
رئيسها في العديد من المحافل اكد على انه
مع التعدديه وليس مع القطب الواحد ولكن من
خلال هذه الوساطه تتمدد هل عينها على راس
القاعده على راس قمه النظام العالمي
اه لا طبعا الصين لا تسعى الى قياده
العالم او يعني توسعوا
الصين يعني
فلسفتهم وقتها يعني تنميه التطور صيني
وتنميه سلميه مختلفه تماما
التطور او التنميه في مفهوم الغربي
فمثلا يعني سبب انجاح الصين في
وساطها هذه المره يعني تثبت
الصين يعني تتمسك تتمسك بمبادئ حسن الجوار
وكذلك الاعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
للدول الاخرى لذلك هذا الحلول الصينيه
نعم وضحت الفكره جزيلا شكرا تماما توقيت
الحلقه نادى رونج ويعقوب سعيد منها
امستردام شكرا لكما السلام عليكم